you all know I've been on a weight loss  Journey here I don't know how long I've  been going but this is when I was like  250 and  um you know a lot of the before and  afters people post they're being nice  and I appreciate the support and stuff  but a lot of it could be like oh that's  an angle that's a camera angle it's hard  to tell but this one you really can  here's Ethan just ugly seven months ago  and then this was Friday look at that  that is a big difference it is that's  awesome so I'm that makes me feel really  really  um  really happy yeah no so the shirts are  less tight obviously and things are  fitting nicer and I'm just feeling  encouraged and happy to see that I'm  finally making progress because for the  longest time it felt like progress was  impossible